hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast
Aurora kinase a drives the evolution of
resistance to the regenerate EGFR
inhibitors in lung cancer presented by
dr. Quixote Shaw postdoctoral research
scholar at University of California San
Francisco I am excited tears of lab
roots and I will be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab Birds labyrinth is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box that appears on the
screen our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Shaw I will now turn the presentation
over to her ankle Hoagland and welcome
to the webinar on or a kinase a drives
the evolution of resistance to the third
generation in the mean learning
objectives in this webinar is that I
will introduce you to the EGFR PKI
mechanism of resistance is limiting
barrier factor therapy also I will
introduce you to the methods for a model
system that we use to study dickwad
resistant and a high content microscopy
based platform that he used to discover
the rationale combination therapy in a
quiet resistance also I will be
discussing about my results however
kinase a or we found that
typical target to overcome the
resistance and the underpinning and the
mechanisms of dissecting the residual
Disney's in addition to that we also
learn about how the by how to design a
biomarker in case of EGFR TTI resistance
and at the end and then give the
conclusion of most and something so on
next and started with this maybe at one
of genomic era lot of genetic drivers
have been and majority of them are
Quiles mutations and EGFR activating
mutations followed by b-raf mutation
pik3ca mutation or any other genomic
changes however major majority of the
patient has on wound genetic drivers as
well but for the purpose of this talk we
are just wanted filters on the EGFR
mutant of tumors that are shown the red
chunk of the pie so EGFR activity was
identified in 1981 EGFR inhibitors were
developed in 1994 and the response the
EGFR was reported in 2000 at that impact
your capital F and a lotta nerve was
optimal in 2004 and ever since that the
therapy has seen success but however
resistance is a major problem as you can
see here in the CT scan on the first at
the time of diagnosis patient presents
with the EGFR exam 19 division and that
tumor has quite highly you can see the
height Union mass at the three months of
the therapy you can see the tumor sizes
three for patient display Alicia
profound response but upon progression
at twenty months the patient's tumor
starts to grow again in this patient is
movement to lotta nerve
and this happen inevitably for most of
the tumors so let's look at how what are
the multiple mechanism of wide
resistance the active cellular level if
we take each a a party is EGFR
activating mutation induces the
downstream signaling in the I 3 kinase
and map kinase pathway which leads to
cell growth and survival
hence EGFR TTI are designed to down
regulate this pi3 kinase and nab kinase
activity however the secondary mutations
in EGFR occur which turns on the
downstream signaling such as CI 3 kinase
signaling resulting in and these genetic
alterations that happens in EGFR are
mean 8790 a mutation or C 787s mutation
additionally the bypass signaling such
as net amplification power to
amplification on P - mutations are also
observed in case of each I pick a
location and is also a bush to pn 3 and
the chinese becoming overwhelming the
cell growth in survival apart from that
the cell state changes or a non genetic
resistance mechanism such as conversion
to small cell or lights or spends
premise differentiation pelvic in type
or epithelial-mesenchymal transition has
been also found there are also reports
book says the NF kappa-b
activity or km v or wind signaling
activity is higher in these patients and
there are omitting changes that occur
when they have known genetic drivers of
resistance that being said I'm just
summarizing that in the chart over here
as you can see each year parties are 90
M mutation is the major resistance
mechanism to false generation engine
power in Twitter it is a lot an F or
giftable however 30 percent of the
patient have known genetic driver
who will be and hence post-invasion EGFR
inhibitor are non-selective 47 idea
mutation and hence the efforts were done
from design the second-generation
some efficacy towards this resistant
mutation but on the toxicity with the
pattern abyss proton because it also
targets of all type for EGFR receptor
resulting in him rash of to the most of
the patient and hence the
third-generation EGFR inhibitors for
design which has specificity towards 37
idea mutation and the EGFR mutations but
not to the wild-type EGFR and as you can
see over here in the waterfall curve
most of the patients respond to the
third generation EGFR inhibitor which
have cheese and meditation however the
response are never complete and most of
the patients who progress power
generation EGFR inhibitor as such Oh
since the efforts are done by the ash
official debut x10 part to identify what
are the genomic driver of the resistance
to the power generation etf are impotent
by using the circulating just a DNA or
using the taxi and what you can see in
this pie chart is that most of the
patient harbored in the amplification
hard to amplification or EGFR of
amplification directly find these
mutations
however 35% of the patient have again
genetic tribal meaning that the non
genetic mechanism don't try and
ultimately it is possible that a genetic
mechanism it's grown from evolution of
this gene but this reach us to ask the
question how does the acquired
resistance evolve in case of AJ for TPI
now this is a CT scan from the patient
at T seminary annotations at third
diagnosis and what pretreated
the Amata make progress on that so this
patient worked on the third generation
EGFR inhibitor and you can see some
response at four months but again the
patient human progress is set for six
months and in this case there is some
attempt education on progression so this
indicates that the tumor is made up of
sensitive cells along with the frame 16
genetic fuels when you treat time with
the first generation or the second
generation EGFR inhibitor the
progression free survival of these
patient have t7 IDM are lesions and are
given power generation EGFR inhibitor on
which also the progress of the bench and
moons of the therapy and these tumors
are immuno refractory and there is no
other treatment options available and
this is a very critical question that we
try to entrance
amudha so that is critical to model
these acquired resistance in being true
and to do that we take how we see the
clinical scenario et / sensitive tumor
so in the third culture we take a
sensitive cell line we treat them with
the EGFR tki in this case our generation
each year 40 K Isis and be steamed
majority of the cells die and at the end
of day 3 there are some cells that
survive the initial treatment and this
is exactly what it correlates into the
clinical setting these patients develop
the residual Mass that that is that is
intolerant to the that is tolerant to
the draw but they do not induce
apoptosis and ultimately the residual
disease go on to become acquired
resistant and cells or two more start
from the waiting again and the patient
progress on the therapy and hence it is
very necessary to understand this
mechanism of resistance and to do that
we took for sensitive cell lines with
two different EGFR inhibitor and develop
eight
quad models of resistance so to to
indicate here with the PC nine cells
which harbored the exon 19 deletion 1975
cells Harbor the l88 are empty seven
idea mutation and then we SEC 8 to 7 and
XE c 6s which are its own dilution and
the resistance are lines that come out
of it is developed is denoted by are
raised by treat prolong treatment of
Simonton air or through long treatment
and as we can see in the colony
formation and i said that these cells
are highly sensitive or peripheral cells
indicated here in we are highly
sensitive to the third generation EGFR
inhibitor but you do see the city of
ourselves in or when you take me a quite
resistant cells they are highly
resistant to both the mono therapy alone
and hence on the ask a question what
would be the good way to characterize
this acquired resistance cells and as
you can see here in pc-9 cells which is
the parent role sensitive cells on the
short term treatment of EGFR inhibitor
is sufficient to decrease the map
signaling limited by decrease in the
phosphor art and phosphate lychee an
induction of three part but the acquired
resistant cells have higher phosphor or
phosphate ET and diminished pathetic
response we further characterize this
acquired resistant models by performing
the whole eight zone or sequencing and
we found no recurrent mutation meaning
that the resistance is not driven by
known genetic driver the resistance was
reversible meaning that when you
withdraw the truck and we shall after 14
days and we challenge them with a truck
they were sensitive as the parental
cells there is no evidence of article
activation based on article array and GC
analysis showed that there is enrichment
of epithelial to mesenchymal transition
cows these cells also
had higher NF kappa-b activity as
reported by the people here at UCSF so
we went on to item we wanted to identify
how how to induce the circling in these
cells and to do that we we developed a
platform which is a high content
microscopy based platform to do a
combination drug screen so in this
screen we take the sensitive cell line
which is 1975 and a resistance R line
which is 1975 roaster retina resistant
cells and people see them on the in a
high throughput manner in 384 well plate
and perform 94 drugs along with the
combination with each particle I our
readout is tapi staining from which
kills the count of cell proliferation as
indicated here in the blue and euro
staining which is indicated in euro
indicates the cell death and we perform
high content automated microscopy and
image analysis and we generate these
metrics which are denotes efficacy
meaning that if the drug has a as a
single agent have higher efficacious
then you see effective combo or they are
not effectiveness that is as a
ineffective although however we are
interested in synergy matrix meaning
that both the truck by itself is not a
factor but as indicated in the Green
Line but the combination is able to
induce alternative so we take this
result convert them into the synergy
score and order them in the rank some
order and I'm going to show the results
from the screen so this was performed in
1975 for select and the resistance cell
line and you can see the top two agents
that
synergizes with P Co one six eight six
and induces the most reduction in cell
proliferation in combination with the
aurora kinase inhibitor easily 1 1 5 2
and V X 6 18
the further validated risk in the
long-term colony formation I say and as
you can see here in the panel BM and so
on the cells are proliferating they are
easily 1 9 to 9 1 which is Lucy Martin
it is also in a factor and mln is a
single agent which is also another
Arakanese inhibitor is ineffective but
the combination of the code can reduce a
circulation also easily 105 - which was
the top fit in the screen and it the
same thing the combination is much
so we confirmed our results in vitro and
also NZ xenograph study when we take the
pc 9 yourself neck resistant cells and
treat them with the single agent versus
the combination you see potent reduction
volume by this time we know that our
combination works highly but why there
is a dependency on our Heinie's
to understand that let me give you a
basic of Arakanese biology our kinase is
a family of four wheeler or kinase the
Rakhine is a beeping hurricane is a
localizes to the spindle pole as
indicated here by the red arrow a is
also involved in regulating the survival
during the mitotic delays or error and
it is regulated by number of upstream
factors such as GPX to certificates to
binds to Aruna and causes lot of
phosphorylation on teammates to
interaction with our kinase a also
limits the binding of phosphatase which
is responsible for the possibility or ie
so meaning that T 2 X 2 is the
coactivator
of our kinase a and why is this
important because in our a quad
resistance cell model we found that as
compared to the parent rod cells
indicated here in free phospho aurora
was higher or Arakanese activation was
higher in the acquired resistance cell
line indicated here in red and
this happens in all four models as you
can see GPX - which is a coactivator of
Aurora is also high in the awkward
resistant models versus the parent model
meaning that 30 plates - is governing
the Arakanese the attribution the next
question is what happens if we
overexpress hurricane YZ e or TP x -
does it confer resistance to the therapy
and the answer is yes so as you can see
here in the blue line is the entrence or
let Z control and then you over so 20%
of the cells survive on a CD 99 on
treatment then you have order a kinase a
or TP x - or unknown Kira's G 12v
mutations these thoughts are able to
survive better and this indicates that
Pia Conti pens - or Aurora kinase
activity is sufficient to induce a part
resistance so this was very intriguing
observation for us now it's sufficient
to induce cell proliferation but is it
sufficient to induce apoptosis that's
the question we asked here and the
answer is yes so the graph here is shown
in case of a PC 9 ml n itself in degree
it doesn't induce cell death indicated
by low you Pro+ cells but the single
agent olsommer turnip and the
combination is able to induce much more
potent offices in pc 9 as well as indeed
resistant cells only in case of a
combination so this leads us to believe
that term we wanted to identify what are
the molecular mechanisms behind the he
seen behind this resistance and to do
that we took the sensitive cell lines
and asked the question there is no
target reactivation case of a
combination or the MLM treatment and the
known phosphor aurora is also not high
in the parent role cells phosphor bin
which is also another mediator of
apoptosis and it's been known by the
study of Brian Horton
the David Costa at dana-farber they
indicated that each a hard drives the
survival by degrading them by increasing
the phosphor a sheen of me so now when
you give each a particular you should
see beam stabilization and down
regulation of phosphorylation of them
and that is what exactly we see in the
parent of a line in name to and the
combinations BIM phosphorylation and
induces the pin stabilization
subsequently it also causes the
stabilization of bats and regulation of
three part meaning that the cells are
under cooking purposes however in case
of a quite resistant cells again we
don't see the activation of hospital for
meaning that these cells doesn't have
ETA for activating mutations these cells
have higher phosphor aura and the
combination is able to remove the high
higher variety also the aurora kinase is
responsible for the avoid avoiding
apoptosis when the cell is undergoing
mitosis and what you can see over it
from here and regulate the stability of
them and in case of awkward resistance
now you can see that the compa the
regulation of phosphor beam is
maintained by two different axes from
EGFR as well as from the MLM and both
the therapy by itself is not sufficient
but when they are used in the
combination it can induce Bhim induce
bags and induce key part in case of a
combination in case of resistance so
this is the underlying mechanism of
synergy that it induces the apoptotic it
regulates the apoptotic
Maalik process so finally do sir
summarize this section or we can see
that the treatment nine cells when
treated with EGFR take AI alone causes
bin stabilization and hence induces
offices however in the acquired
resistance cells sense a parallel
dependency related by phosphorylation of
Aurora which phosphorylates build and
degrades them but when you use the
combination of of EGFR and Iraq I name
you see no correlation of them and hence
the beam is able to stabilize and use
purposes so this is a protein synthetic
lethal interaction where process the
gene a which is EGFR is governing the
apoptosis and gene B which is a refine
ease is governing the apoptosis and then
you just inhibit the pathway a the
apoptosis is not abrogated the
combination of the two is required in
order to have a synthetic lethal
interaction and and that is the reason
of the potent synergy that we see in the
combination its compact combination
therapy alone requires with themselves
so moving on to asking a big question
how does the acquired resistance so just
to give you a perspective of what we
know in the literature until now there
are pre-existing t7 idea mutations that
happen and which Pavoni acquired
resistance force generation or TTI or
there is a per sister evolution of
phenotype meaning that these terms are
initially sensitive they enter into the
residual like state which have the t7 ID
and flow and developed a t7 IDM positive
flow but this is in case of a
first-generation EGFR receptor it is
also known that prolonged treatment of
EGFR inhibitor causes this residual
cells found that are called DTP or a
drought-tolerant versus their cells and
when these cells are capping drugs they
start cycling and they become DTE piece
which is acquired
etheline and Jeff settlement group in
Genentech had shown that these cells are
gtps have higher chromatin condensation
in them but until now there is no clear
answer how the cells transition between
the sensitive state to rock tolerant
persister or a renewal cells to the
upward resistance cells also there is
one study from the Altucher group here
at UCSF where they expanded the
sensitive pc9 cells from a single cell
clone and they made 17 different cell
line and kept them in the culture for
long term for about 50 degrees and they
asked the questions the cell lines that
come from these what are the genetic
changes in them by performing the genome
sequencing and as you can see here that
the the lines are on the y-axis and the
changes that happens in the genomic
changes are on the x axis and you can
see most of the cells have either EGFR
mutations in them met amplification de
la la mutation and grass activation or
map kinase 2 mutation and that is also
the high high dependency on a ap or take
we see a mutation consistently what has
been reported in the literature however
this is a very long term treatment and
we don't know what what is in between
and hence too so it leads us to ask the
question can residual cells give rise to
a quiet resistance also do these
residual cells have targetable world
number one never ability that they can
be targeted and does the suppression of
the residual self prevent the emergence
of a quiet resistance and hence we went
back to our model of acquired resistance
and the residual cells so in this case
from day 3 - day 9 we have a residual
cells and we ask the question what are
the what are the chain
just that happen upon the drug treatment
over a period of time and to do that we
perform the Western blot analysis at the
time that are indicated over here in the
parent role 1975 which is a sensitive
cell line and MV 19 md5 AR which is the
upward resistance online and clearly
what you can see over here is that the
treatment of ease 89 to 91 which is the
ocean water name is able to reduce the
population of each layer far throughout
dot treatment duration the target an
activation is not taking place
however the TP X 2 which is the
co-activator of Aurora needs starts to
go high at the end of 24 hours and it's
maintained throughout the residual phase
and in the acquired resistance cells
also it increases tickets to is known to
stabilize and activate our high knees
and hence we see the temporal activation
of our kinase followed by TP x 2
activation at 24 hours and these cells
in the residual state have higher high
knees as well in terms of
phosphorylation of BIM these cells are
able to suppress the phosphorylation of
them and when the arrow kinase
activation occurs he serves now is able
to phosphorylate BIM and destabilize
them so in the sensitive cells you can
see that in the sensitive face from the
day to today sorry at all hours to date
too these cells are able to induce
apoptosis but from day 2 onwards they
enter into the torrent cells and they
have abrogated p apoptosis might be
stabilizing him and hence we can use
this model of residual cells to study
the residual disease in clinic and so we
ask the question does activation of
phosphoric appens with the other EGFR
take a I as well in the answer is yes as
you can see here in the graph that pc9
that are sensitive cells when they
returned with the indicated first
generation second generation and third
generation
EGFR inhibitor over here respectively is
able to induce a pop it's able to induce
the aura Heinie's activation tips to is
also high in the mental are able to
activate the opposite by destabilizing
and then the question is that how can we
prevent the emergence of a part
resistance so this is performed by a
prolonged treatment day 90 treatment of
the individual therapy and what you can
see over here is that pc9 cells without
any treatment proliferate but and so I
think presence of ironies in Twitter
alone in case of a single agent EGFR
therapy indicated here in orange and in
green the cells enter there is an
initial response and then the cells
enter into the residual phase and then
after day 30 they start going back again
but when you treat them upfront with the
combination therapy its able to reduce
the cell proliferation by in a profound
manner so that you don't see the
activation of cell proliferation and
cell growth the other question is what
happens when we have the residual cells
so here we made the residual cells and
then we asked the question what happens
in presence of combination therapy and
what you can see in the red and the pink
line is that the combination is able to
remove this residual cells meaning that
it has a potential of eliminating the
recipe to confirm this we took the PDX
temples that were derived from the EGFR
L 858 our mutation some mutation tumor
on these patient this patient was
initially responding to a lot early but
however they developed the residual
disease and that's where the biopsy was
taken and the patient arrived children
was made wrong on this residual tumor
doesn't have the moon genetic aberration
such as to seminary a mutation or any
other and in the paper in the cell
report paper cotton black whale shows
that these have higher and
Furby activity so we use this a pdf's
model to ask the question does can it is
it sensitive to the third-generation
EGFR inhibitor alone and what is its
efficacy in the combination so as you
can see over here is that the the PD
exits are rows when there is no
treatment when you give our kinase
inhibitor alone or in the green bar the
tumor is flipping single agent Jose
Martinez which is the ETF party ki is
also able to not able to reduce the cell
proliferation
although these patients have indications
but the combination does much better job
in preventing the tumor growth of the
periods meaning that the combination is
highly synergistic and again we perform
the molecular or signaling studies by
performing immunoblot and we show here
that the EGFR inhibitors alone induces
gbx2
and the combination is able to abrogate
the TP X 2 which is a resistant marker
and POSCO
Arora these cells also have diminished
ospa beam and there's a beam
stabilization that happens in the
combination along with the creeper
conduction so this combination is situs
toxic compared to cytostatic also we
identify chip x2 as a marker of
resistance meaning that the patient who
progress on EGFR tki or the tumors PDS
tumors that progressed on EGFR tki
have higher jpx to staining as indicated
by the IHC on staining over here in the
picture also tip x2 is highly up
regulated in the patient who progressed
on or Naughton em so shown here in the
panel are two patient which have which
the verb biopsied at the time of
diagnosis
by a and at the time of progression
indicated by P so as you can see in six
out of nine patient the TPX two went
higher in case of resistance meaning
that term GPX to is a marker of
therapeutic resistance and as you
combine there is a statistically
significant difference in the tickets to
iets see spore in the patient who
progress on first-generation EGFR
inhibitor also we took the three samples
that were identified from
third-generation EGFR inhibitor and as
you can see luring the IOC the
pretreatment and TK Odessa spent humours
thirty ki resistant tumors have
significant higher I had C of T V X 2 so
this makes us believe that Chipettes two
could be a potent biomarker for the for
therapy resistance
so to summarize my finding so far the
treatment is treatment reduces the
activation of Anwar kinase which is
associated with the resistance to EGFR t
ki depends to plays an important role in
Iraq I need a activation addict
contributes to the upward resistance for
T debates to can serve as a biomarker of
treatment of resistance and Aurora needs
a activation deregulate the be mediated
apoptotic pathway in the residual cells
and hence the combination is and hence
the inactivation of our refine is a list
of as a synthetic lethal strategy for
enhancing the responses to each party I
with that I would like to thank my lap
and my P I saw about the party I and the
lab members along with her awesome
collaborators from the Vimala
who assisted in my studies you see
yourself pathologic group bigger things
for performing the pathology of the
sample Google app Dumont lab McCormick
lab and my funding and
ucsf Helen Diller family so thank you
all and this is accepted in the nature
medicine so this paper should come out
in couple of months and please cite our
work and let me know if you have any
questions thank you thank you dr. Shaw
for the informative presentation we will
now start the Q&A portion of the webinar
and we'll address some of the most
commonly asked questions by our viewers
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question drop-down box located on
the far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email now let's
get started our first question is can
genetic and non-genetic mechanisms
coexist what is the clinical implication
this is a good question and yes the
answer is genetic and non-genetic
commitments can coexist on beeping that
our reckoning helps in the evolution of
the resistance mechanisms and ultimately
the tone that is fit to survive will
survive in the tumor and give rise to a
genetic resistance it's being shown that
multiple genetic drivers as well as
known genetic drivers are present in the
clinical of patients progress on each 40
ki and hence it is important to study
the genetic and non-genetic mechanisms
and in a resistance of EGFR CK CK I is
always the genetic mechanism or do not
non-genetic mechanisms exist in such a
case the for the innate resistance
mechanisms or other 97-90 and plays the
same role there is no other known
genetic mechanism that can give rise to
innate resistance and hence it is mainly
that the mountains
I would like to once again thank dr.
Shah for her presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing January of 2019
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast would
be available for replay we share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye